رعب حول العالم جهاز يسرق الباسوردات
ومتاح للبيع اون لاين وباقل الاسعار
تيك توك تفاوض حكومه الاردن لرفع الحظر
واردنيون يتوسلون للحكومه رجعوا التطبيق
طفشنا من الفي بي ان واول سوبر سياره
صناعه طالبان انجاز سوبر مضحك اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
منتشر على كل منصات تحذيرات من جهاز جالس
بين قال انه قادر على ثقه بيانات وكلمات
سر اي بطاقه او هاتف بمجرد المرور من
جانبها وطبعا الجهاز عامل حاله من او عام
الحاله من الذعر عند الكل
ترى حاله الرعب هذه عالميه وعلى تيك توك
تحديدا بدات الفيديوهات بالانتشار ومن
هناك انتقلت لباقي من الصوت
والهاشتاج على تيك توك على النصف مليار
مشاهده بكل اللغات
والعربي منها كما طبعا شوفوا بعض المقاطع
اللي بتتكلم عن الجهاز وبتحضر منه
يعتبر هذا الجهاز من اخطر اجهزه التهكير
اللي ترعبك وتدعيلك حرفيا بنفس الوقت وانا
وان هذا الفيديو لاسباب تعليميه فقط
والغريب ان هذا الجهاز متوفر في المتاجر
ومتناول يد الجميع طبعا هذا الجهاز اسمه
فليبر زيرو اول ما تشوفه حسب اللعبه ولكن
لا تنخدع بالمظاهر لان هذا الجهاز جهاز
دمار شامل اقصد جهاز تعليمي متعدد المهام
اغلبكم الحين يتساءل ايش يقدر عليه هذا
الجهاز هذا الجهاز يقدر ينسخ الاشاره في
النطاق اللي موجود فيه ينسخ الاشاره ويفتح
ابواب السيارات والانفسي والابواب سياره
والبطائق البنكيه الجوالات المغلقه او
الحسابات وحتى التلفزيونات وغيرها كثير
اداء فعلا
[موسيقى]
اغرب اختراع ظهر لنا في 20 23 ولكن اتصدمت
لما لقيت ان الفيديو جاب اكثر من 36 مليون
مشاهده والعدد ده بسبب الاختراع اللي اسمه
في ليفربول
الموجوده في الفنادق وفتح العربيات وكمان
تشغيل التلفزيونات بالاضافه لانه يقدر
ينسخ الكروت البنكيه وتدفع من خلاله وكل
ده لان معتمد على احدث تقنيات الاي اي
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتوا الجهاز اسمه فليبر زيرو وهو
جهاز متوفر للبيع على امازون وباقي
المتاجر الالكترونيه وباسعار رخيصه جدا
على فكره يعني والجهاز بيجمع تقنيات اجهزه
اخرى عديده وقادر على انه يصير جهاز واحد
عنده اكسس على ريموتات اي اجهزه فمثلا
الجهاز هذا ممكن من خلاله تفتح السياره
تشغل المكيف والتليفزيون والبيت وغيرها
وكمان ممكن يعمل سكان للهويه الشخصيه
وبطاقات التعريف وبنجال انه كمان بمجرد
مرور ومن جنب اي جهاز تليفون ممكن ينسخ كل
الكلمات السر لاي برامج او من الصاج بما
فيها كلمات سر البنوك والبطاقات البنكيه
كمان مع حاله الدعاء الشديد اللي عملها
الجهاز بين الناس على المنصات طلع مغتصين
ومنهم هكذا محترفين
ومتخصصين وقالوا يا جماعه بطلوا مبالغه
الكلام هذا مو صحيح وما في جهاز ممكن يعمل
كل هذا
صحيح وايش الحقيقه حول هذا الجهاز خلينا
نفهم اكثر لما نسال طبعا مختص بينضم الينا
من الرياض خبير الامن السيبراني محمد علي
الغامدي اهلا فيك معنا يا محمد همم انت
جالس بتضحك هل بتضحك لانه الجهاز فعلا
خطير ولازم تحذرنا منه ولا لان الناس
بتبالغ
حياك الله اهلا بالعزيزه ساره
لانه الزخم الاعلامي الموجود على وهم
يخلقه الخوف من السرقه ومن بعض الادوات
اللي الناس يشوفونها كنا سحر همم
طب اول شيء هذا الجهاز هو اتصنع ليش يعني
ايش الهدف منه
طيب الجهاز ما في اي شيء جديد الجهاز كل
الاشياء اللي فيه موجوده اوريدي في اجهزه
والاجهزه هذه يمكن بعضها عمرها 10 سنوات
او اكثر من 10 سنوات طيب الحلو المميز في
هذا الجهاز انه يجمع هذا كل كل الخواص
التقنيه هذه في جهاز واحد
اللي هي ايش هذه الخواتم
طيب بشكل عام اممم التحكم
بالترددات الراديويه
نسخها حفظها وكتابتها ولكنها فعاله فقط
على بروتوكولات قديمه لا تستخدم في او ضمن
الاجهزه الحساسه او نقول البروتوكولات
الحساسه جدا مثل اجهزه فك ال ال او
الريموتات الخاصه بفك السيارات
بكل اللي يسويه الجهاز بشكل فعلي هو نسخ
تردد حفظه
وارساله او كتابته على جهاز اخر بالاضافه
الى خاصيه اسمها باديو اس بي هذه نوع من
انواع الاتاكس او نوع من انواع الهجمات
الالكترونيه اللي قد تستخدم لزرع اكواد
خبيثه اذا كان متصل باجهزه لكن مره اخرى
هذا خاصيه موجوده في جهاز اطلق في 2012 اه
وكثير في بروتوكولات الحمايه من مثل هذا
الخصيه
ايش قصدك بانه بياخذ تردد
همم اغلب الوايرلس كونكشنز اللي يصير في
حياتنا زي فتح المكيف تحضير القنوات من
خلال جهاز التحكم بال تي في همم وما الى
ذلك تصير عن طريق موجات راديويه همم
تردد موجود على تردد معين همم نفس الشيء
موجود في الجهاز اللهم انه ينسخ يخزن
ويكثر طيب الان الناس بتنزل فيديوهات
وبتنزل وفي منهم حتى يعني خبراء في
التقنيه وكاتبين فيه مواقع يعني هي معروفه
من مواقع التقنيه بيقولوا انه الا فعلا
جربوا الجهاز والجهاز النسخ المعلومات حق
الباسوردات والاشياء هذه كلها
طيب في اشياء الجهاز مستحيل يسويها مهما
يعني
قالوها خاصه وتقنيه ما تاهله ااا ولانو
هذا الشمس مستحيل تصيروا بشكل وايرلس اول
شيء نسخ كلمات السر الخاصه بحسابات
نسخ كلمات السر الخاصه بالبنوك
نسخ اي شيء من الجوال
اذا الا في حاله انه الجهاز كان موصل بي
usb في الجوال والجوال كان مسموح يعني
يسمح للجهاز انه يقدر يدخل وياخذ اكسس
عليه يقدر الجهاز وقته انه هو يزرع كود
خبيث ويتحكم بمحتم بالجواله ومحتويات
الجوال بالكامل
عدا او غير ذلك الجهاز يعني فعليا الشيء
المميزه الوحيد في انه يجمع خواص لاجهزه
كثيره
بيعدوا من جنب الشخص وبياخذه الباسوردات
طيب كيف تفسر هذه الفيديوهات اللي شايفين
نشوفها على تيك توك ايش بيصير
بيكذبوا علينا يعني
طيب انا ما ادري اي فيديو تحديدا تقولين
عليه لكن اقدر مثلا
هذا غير صحيح ابدا الجهاز اذا مررت فيه
على بطاقه فيزا مثلا بينسخ الايدي الخاص
بالبطاقه لكن مستحيل ينسخ اي معلومات اخرى
والاي دي هذا لحاله غير مفيد ومستحيل احد
استخدمه عشان يسرق فلوس او ما لها ذلك طيب
مره اخرى
شف لنا فيديوهات ثانيه كمان يعني برده
مقلقه يعني لما انا اقدر مثلا انه اتحكم
في انه مثلا جراج احد ينفتح ولا ما ينفتح
لان انا مثلا ادخل مطعم وفجاه التصفي لهم
الاضاءه بالجهاز يعني هذه كلها اشياء
خطيره الصراحه برده
صحيح اتفق معك هذا شيء صحيح الجهاز يسويها
لانه اغلب الاجهزه هذه لها ريموتات
والريموتات لها ترددات وغالبا غير امنه
ومالها بروتوكولات معينه للحمايه من قبل
اجهزه قد تنسخ الترددات هذه وتقوم باعاده
ارسالها فصحيح هذا الشيء موجود الشيء
الوحيد اللي نقدر نحنا نسويه عشان نتلاقى
مثل هذا الحوادث انه اللهم نستخدم اجهزه
لها خلينا نقول بروتوكولات امن همم سواء
خاصه بالكراج او خاصه يعني الجهاز يستخدم
او فعال على اجهزه لاستخدم بروتوكولات
قديمه فغالبا هذا الاجهزه رخيصه همم لكن
في اجهزه اخرى يعني تستخدم نوع من انواع
تشالنج خلينا نقول في عمليه همم ارسال
واستقبال الترددات الخاصه
والتتيح للجهاز انه يفتح او يقفل همم
هذه الاجهزه
من قديمه او مش عارفه ايه بس مثلا هذا
الشيماء بينطبق على مثلا سيارات تسلا
سيارات تسلا اللي يصير في سيارات تسلا انا
اللي شفته انه الجهاز يفتح همم المدخل حق
الشحن
والسندوق وهذه
ايوه وهذه وهذه خاصيه موجوده في اي شاحن
كهربائي اذا اخذتي اي شاحنه اذا عندك
سياره تسله رحت عند اي شاحن كهربائي متسله
وقدمت راس الشاحن قريب من ال- من الفتحه
بفتح
حق الصندوق تردد موجود ما له اي حمايه
لانه اعتقد الشركه انه ما يحتاج حمايه
وكثير شركات تقدر تصنيع نفس هذا الانبوب
وتقدر تفتح فيه فتحه الشحن الخاصه
بالسياره
انت بتقول ما يقدر ينقل المعلومات البنكيه
ما يقدر ياخذ الباسوردات لكن اذا الانسان
او شخص جاء قرر يستخدم بطريقه فيها اذيه
ناس ثانيين او مثلا ضرر لهم من ناحيه انه
يتحكم في محلات اضاءه تكييف ما نعرف ايش
يقدر يتحكم بهذا الشيء
حيقدر ياذيهم
عم يقدر
يسوي هذا الشيء ليش لانه هذا الاضاءه او
هذا التلفزيون وهذا المكيف يستخدم تردد
[موسيقى]
من بدري من بعد اكثر من شهر يعني على حضر
تكتب في الاردن شركه تيك توك اخيرا خرجت
عن صمتها واصدرت بيان امس اعلنت في
المحادثات بينها وبين الحكومه الاردنيه
لرفع الحظر عن التطبيق وقال البيان انه
الشركه بتؤمن بالتوصل لقرار يسمح للمنظم
وصلت خدمه الملايين من صانعي المحتوى
والمستخدمين في الاردن وعرض البيانات عن
هاشتاج مفيده
154 مليون مشاهده في الاردن تحديدا وهشتاق
مثلا
138 مليون مشاهده في الاردن ايضا بيان تيك
توك تاكد كمان انه فرق الشركه راح تواصل
اتخاذ الاجراءات ضد اي محتوى بنت هيك
القواعد الاجتماعي
ازاله اكثر من
310,000 مقطع مخالف في الاردن اكثر 86%
منهم انشالوا قبل ما يحصدوا اي مشاهدات
وهذا انه يعني تبر دليل على انه عندهم
سرعه في الاجراءات طبعا للتذكير مشاهدينا
نحنا وحده الجرائم الالكترونيه في الاردن
اعلنت في بيان في ديسمبر عن ايقاف تطبيق
تيك توك مؤقتا لعدم تعامل المنصه مع اساءه
استخدامها من قبل بعض المستخدمين سواء
بمجدوه او بينشروا اعمال العنف او دعوات
الفوضى وكان هذا خلال احتجاجات على ارتفاع
اسعار المحروقات تخللتها اعمال العنف
ووفاه عقيده الاردنيين من وقت القرار
تحولوا لتطبيقات على الحظر واستخدام تيك
توك وعبر فيديوهات من هناك او حتى من
الصوت الاخرى في اردني يجلس بلا نجد
السلطات انه يرجعوا لهم تيك توك وبيانات
لشركه سمبل للتحليلات اظهرت اقبال كبير
على تطبيقات الفي بي ان في الاردن وزياده
كبيره في مرات التحميل هذه التطبيقات تص
قوائم الاكثر تحميلا على متجر اب ستور
الايام الماضيه واحتلت المراتب الاربعه
الاولى اما على متجر جوجل بلاي احتلت الفي
بي ان خمس مراتب من ال 10 مراتب للتطبيقات
الاكثر تحميلا اما اخر التصريحات الصادره
عن الحكومه الاردنيه فكانت من يومين وعلى
لسان وزير الاقتصاد الرقمي والاردن احمد
الهنانده اللي قال انه ما في اي اخبار او
يعني عوده التطبيق
اهلا من جديد عنوان خبرنا الجاي هو اغلى
جلسه ليزر يمكن في التاريخ ففي ثلاثه من
لاعبين نادي الزمالك مصطفى شلبي محمد صبحي
وعبد الله جمعه نشر صور لهم في احدى
عيادات الاطباء المعروفين وهم بيعملوا
جلسات ليزر لازاله الشعر
والصور هذه كلفتهم 300 الف جنيه
الصور اللي شفتوها نشروها اللاعبين على
صفحاتهم الشخصيه وهو بيعملوا او هم
بيعملوا جلسات ليزر ويبدو انه دعايه لاحد
العيادات ولكن رجعوا حذفوها من بعد
الانتقادات ففي ناس شايفه انه عيب نشر شيء
مثل هذا حتى لو كانوا بيعملوا ليزر وانا
شايف انه هذا مو من الرجوله اصلا
على التوقيت كان الصوره النادي بيستعد
لمباراه مهمه وفي ناس حاول الموضوع لماده
للنكت
بعد التعليقات والجدل والغضب اللي صار
اداره نادي الزمالك ووفق مصادر من داخل
النادي غير متلاعبين 300 الف جنيه لكن مو
واضح للانسه بالغرام يعني هي مشكلتهم في
الليزر ولا فكره الاعلان من اساسه ولا انه
اعلان غير لائق للتوقيت ولا ايش ما نعرف
[موسيقى]
ما زالت اغنيه النجمه شاكيرا متصدر
الاخبار والمنصات ومازالت الترند رقم واحد
على يوتيوب ومشاهده وصلت ل 132 مليون
مشاهده وطبعا نحن بنتكلم عن الاغنيه اللي
وجهتها شاكيرا بشكل غير مباشر لحبيبها
السابق جيرار بيكي ورمت في كلام كثير على
انفصالهم القصه المتداوله لكلنا خلاص
سمعناها انه خانها مع بنت عمرها 22 سنه
والان مصاحبها لهذه البنت شاكيرا نزلت
الاغنيه الناريه ومن بعدها شفنا حرب
التصريحات مو بس بينها وبين البيكين لا
كمان دخلت الشركات مثل كاسيو ورينو عندهم
سياره
واللي شبهها فيهم شاكيرا حبيبه الجديده
دخلت في الموضوع كمان الجديد اللي راح
اتكلم فيه وهو يبدو انه فيه جانب مضيء من
قصه شاكيرا الحزينه والنجاح يمكن يعزيها
فخيل الاربع ايام الماضي بس شاكيرا ربحت
من الاغنيه الجديده مليونين ونصف دولار
نشرات على التلفزيون اسباني شاكيرا ربحت
مليون و200,000 من سماء الناس للاغنيه عبر
ابل واكثر من نص مليون من يوتيوب ومثلهم
من امازون هذا غير
360,000 من سبوتفايل وعلى فكره هذه ثالث
اغنيه بتترحها شاكيرا من وقت الانفصال عن
بيكي وموضوعها الخيانه والانفصال وهذول بس
بحسب بيانات التلفزيون الاسباني الان
مجموعه ارباحهم يعني 15 مليون دولار الله
يبارك لها صراحه حقيقه وطبعا ما ننسى كمان
انه بيكي ربح هو ايضا بعد عقد رعايه كاسيو
يعني ثنائي صراحه دروس في فن تحويل الماسي
لمكاسب
[موسيقى]
طيب طالبان يبدو حلف ما توقف تذهلنا وهذه
الايام جالسه بتحتفل بانجاز شايفين تاريخي
وحدث مهم جدا والمتحدث باسم الحركات ذبيح
الله مجاهد هو اللي ضيف او اللي دف لنا
الخبر الرهيب ونشر الفيديو على حسابه على
تويتر
[موسيقى]
انا شفت المونتاج والاضاءه والتفحيط في
الاستعراض يعني طلبان يعني تعبانه يعني في
المقطع اللي بتتباها فيه باول سياره من
صنعها
لكن الحقيقه انه الانجاز وهمي وبس وهمي لا
والله انجاز مضحك كمان يعني في السياره
الي اسمها ماده تسعه وطالبان بتقول لنا
اول سوبر سياره افغانستان افغانيه وانه
اشتغل عليها 30 مهند
سياره محطوط فيها محرك تويوتا كورولا حتى
تويوتا كورولا موديل
حتى ما قالت السياره دفع امامي ولا خلفي
يعني وما في اي سوره حتى للسياره من جوه
طبعا رئيس الهيئه المصنعه للسياره قال انه
السياره تبدا من سيارتها من افغانستان
ويعمل انها توصل للعالم ما اعتقد هتوصل
لاي مكان يعني على فكره وقال كمان انها مو
للبيع حتى الان مع انه جاءتهم طلبات عده
شراءهم
[موسيقى]
وانا مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعل لكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]